mr. Trump says his decision to withdraw
from the Paris climate Accord was based
on economics for more on this were
joined by Brian Deese current senior
fellow at the Harvard Kennedy School of
Government and former senior advisor to
President Obama Brian played a key role
in negotiating the Paris agreement he
joins us from Portland Maine Brian good
morning morning let's just start first
with the practicalities of all of this
while there has been a lot of
consternation and controversy
surrounding the president's decision it
is inherently a four-year process to get
the u.s. out of the Paris agreement what
does that mean and why was it arranged
in such a fashion well that's right and
ironically the first day that officially
the US could withdraw is the day after
the 2020 presidential election so some
time from now it was structured that way
because this agreement was met with the
long view in mind and so countries all
around the world for the first time in
history came together in common cause to
try to do something about climate change
and so the process to get there was long
and the process to withdraw was also
intended to be significant Ryan the
president said he's open to
renegotiating this is that a viable
option I think that's incoherent you
have to understand what the actual Paris
agreement is the Paris agreement is
based on voluntary commitments by
countries so nobody outside the United
States is imposing anything on our
country we set our own target we we make
our own plan
so if President Trump wants to get
serious about climate change and wants
to put forward his own strategy for how
to address this issue
he's completely free to do so under the
agreement I think this notion of
renegotiation is largely an attempt to
hide behind what is really an act of
America retreating from the world Brian
what about the fact that the president
makes the case for the economic argument
that this is going to cost American jobs
what is your response to that look I
think this is all about economics and
the truth is right now around the world
there is a race for who is going to be
the clean energy superpower of the 21st
century this hold outdated idea that
somehow we have to trade-off between
protecting our air and water
and growing our economy is just no
longer true the United States has seen
consistent job growth for the last eight
years under President Obama while
reducing our emissions more than any
other major economy so the truth is this
is about economics there are more than
three million Americans who work in
clean energy and energy efficiency
around the country in towns across the
country good construction jobs saving
people money by upgrading the efficiency
of their homes and those are the kinds
of jobs that are growing faster in the
economy right now and the kind of jobs
we should want more of so we should be
trying to position ourselves to win
those jobs in the future and win those
export opportunities in the future not
retreating into a defensive crouch and
saying that we should stand with Syria
and Nicaragua while the rest of the
world tries to get those economic
benefits Brian we're seeing some
companies and Cu not just some companies
and CEOs but some states actually make
their own commitments to the the Accords
in effect how much can they actually do
well look you're right you've seen every
major US company come out and say this
is the right thing to do and in fact
that when this administration is far to
the right of Exxon on an issue around
climate you know that something's wrong
every American business understands that
the future is moving toward cleaner
sources of energy and that's true for
governors Republican governors and
Democratic governors who have those jobs
in those industries in their states it's
true for cities too that have a lot of
the action concretely around how to
protect their citizens from the threats
of climate change so I think what you're
going to see starting early next week is
an increasing volume of voices from
governors from theirs and from CEOs
saying even if this federal
administration is stepping back we're
going to move forward we're going to
continue our plans to reduce emissions
and that will hopefully send a signal to
the world that even though this
administration isn't with the program
America can still show some leadership
on climate change Brian Deese thank you
very much for being with us this morning
have you be here